one of the hardest things to get right
is how to make a great supervillain and
this seems like filmmakers are just
starting to get the hang of there
there's a mind-blowing roster of classic
comic book buddies who are going to be
hitting theaters over the next couple of
years
scrolls are a nasty species of
shape-shifting aliens that have existed
since the early days of Marvel Comics in
Captain Marvel the most notable one will
be Talos played by Ben Mendelsohn in the
comics
Talos is a relatively obscure character
OB it's a vicious warrior he's certainly
an unexpected choice for our first major
scroll character in the MCU his quality
as a movie villain remains to be seen
but a word of caution for viewers of
Captain Marvel whenever you're dealing
with Scrolls things are never what they
seem
who else who else is a scroll and where
are they we are everywhere you will see
he may have died in the first guardians
of the galaxy film about Ronan the
accuser the fanatical Kree warlord will
play a role than the upcoming Captain
Marvel not only is it generally great to
see Lee pay's return it also makes a lot
of sense for him to be there Captain
Marvel is a prequel and the cria heavily
featured in Carol Danvers origin yet
Ronan might not end up being an
antagonist at all throughout the comics
Ronan is devoted to doing what he feels
is in the best interest of the Crais
sometimes he's trying to eliminate
Earth's pesky superheroes but sometimes
he's teaming up with them basically he's
a total wild card it is the tinder on
which
since the first trailer fans have been
tentatively optimistic about mark
Strong's casting as a beefier than usual
dr. sivana in the upcoming Shazam to the
uninitiated dr. sivana might seem like a
checklist of the most generic villain
qualities throughout all of fiction was
somehow given human form mainly due to
appearing way back in 1939 he's an evil
bald doctor and his actual catchphrases
cur says the movie Savannah appears to
resemble the recent new 52 design where
he's more of a three-dimensional human
being than a cackling madman although it
would be really fun if Mark Strong went
full maniacal villain odds are good that
he's going to be playing Savannah pretty
straight without question one of the
scariest villains and super heroic
history is Jean Grey's alter-ego Dark
Phoenix unfortunately we haven't had a
screen adaptation yet that is fully
delivered on the potential of a
character in the comics Jean bonds with
an alien entity known as the Phoenix
force while on a mission in space which
in time becomes malevolent and genocidal
eventually an entire army of aliens
shows up to put our Phoenix down and
despite the x-men's attempts to save her
she dies in a spectacular final battle
on the moon the movies are taking
another shot at this iconic story with
this summer's Dark Phoenix both a
character be able to rise from the ashes
of a previous incarnations depends on
which version of the x-men franchise it
shows up this summer the good
personality or the evil one
Dark Phoenix herself isn't the only
potentially epic x-men body coming to
the screen this summer perhaps even more
intriguing as a supporting role that's
at this stage we know far less about
Jessica Chastain is going to appear in
Dark Phoenix as someone according to
director Simon Kinberg she is playing a
new character partially inspired by the
mastermind the mastermind is an old
c-list Marvel character with
mind-control powers who in the comics
was partially responsible for Phoenix
turning bad this version of the
character seems like it's going to be
very different from the mustachioed
creep of the comics not only because
this version is a woman but also because
she's apparently going to be an alien
the filmmakers have been cagey about
revealing much else but there's still an
entire universe of possibilities for
what could be going on with this
character played by Mila Jovovich Nimmo
a the Blood Queen is the Hellboy vs
incarnation of the Lady of the lake once
a human protege of Merlin her lust for
power led her to betray Merlin Nemo a
later discovered the OGG drew jihad in
two-dimensional space gods that empower
her to become the strongest magic user
in the world and a conduit through which
they might someday be able to enter it
all so she can turn into a dragon that's
cool we'll see how much of this sends up
on-screen but the trailer shows Hellboy
wielding Excalibur and the promise of
our favorite demon boy using a magic
sword to fight a space dragon which is
certainly enough to get us excited your
fall should be like the fall of
mountains before I was in the beginning
and shall
typically cuddly Ewan McGregor has been
cast as a Batman villain Roman sionis
aka black mask in the birds-of-prey film
from what we can see in the brief teaser
trailer however he is suspiciously
massless in the comics sionis was a
childhood friend of Bruce Wayne who
started desperately committing crimes
while wearing a black mask Bruce tried
to get him to reform but his fate was
sealed when a flaming building collapsed
on him and his mask permanently fused
into his face from then on he was an
irredeemable criminal based on what
we've seen from preliminary plot
synopses it's looking more likely that
sionis is going to be all bad from the
beginning and that's also exciting
current day black mask has not only
terrifyingly cruel but he also has a
magic mask that hypnotize as anyone who
looks directly at her considering harley
quinn fought against black magic and
Suicide Squad it's totally plausible
that this version of black mask might
not just be a ruthless crime boss but
also a master of mentalism don't be
nervous kid but if you keep staring at
me like that I'm gonna cut your eyes out
the trailer for spider-man far from home
introduce us to Jake Gyllenhaal playing
a character who is long overdue for a
big-screen debut Mysterio Mysterio's
main gimmick is that he commits crimes
with the help of illusions often
holographic projections at first glance
Gyllenhaal's portrayal looks like it
might be a radical reinterpretation of
the character in the sense that he's
acting like a mystic superhero bird as
is often the case with old fishbowl
there is probably some deception of
foot's in his first comic appearance he
framed spider-man for a string of
robberies and then presents himself as a
new superhero who will bring spider-man
to justice
Wonder Woman 1984 will feature Kristen
Wiig as cheetah one of wonder woman's
longest-running and most compelling foes
Barbara Minerva was a knowledge hungry
archaeologist who befriended Diana
Prince
Minerva's obsession with ancient secrets
led her to tracking down an evil plant
deity named as Kartika the deity cursed
her by transforming her into a half
cheetah monster with a taste for human
flesh Minerva blamed Diana for not
saving her as she promised and the two
muffin enemies ever since if properly
executed this has the potential to be a
truly heartbreaking story and our hopes
are officially up blaming me changes
nothing
don't deny you cursed me Diana you
brought it on yourself check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about superheroes are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]